so it came out when I was 11 and
I actually didn't even start watching it
until I was about 16 so it came out when
I was 11 I didn't really know much about
it cuz I was just like okay it's
medieval really care that much but then
um so only somebody oh it's so good so
great I was like okay whatever and when
I saw that first episode I was like damn
it's good my connection to Game of
Thrones is very new I took a long time
to get around to see it and I had this
idea for a movie I was like I would love
Peter Dinklage to be in this film and my
roommate was like well then you have to
watch Game of Thrones you just have to
see him do it I was like fine and I
watched it and sooner then sooner than
later I was on season 7 yeah it was
amazing my connection in Game of Thrones
is basically I'm a premium cable junky
snob i HBO market is something HBO
orders something a series and I'll give
it a try and they the trailer that was
for it was incredible
I remembers Sopranos in the 90s and ever
since then you know III watch anything
on HBO and then I saw the first episode
and that was sucks and I'm not even a I
didn't even heard of the books I'm not a
fantasy or sci-fi or anything kind of
person but the characters the execution
it was just another fantastic HBO show
so I was hooked right then
very much yep clear it doesn't matter
because it's so fun to watch but no at
this point you don't even realize that
it's a it's a whole world it's a planet
there's continents and languages and
religions that are all made up you don't
even realize because everything at the
beginning the White Walkers you don't
even know what that is you all you know
is that everyone doesn't believe that
it's real so all you know is that you
want to watch more I think for me having
seen it so recently and now watching it
again it seeing all the foreshadow
that's when I'm like oh that's what that
men do you know and so having seen it
yes it's very clear where it's gonna
like I'm like oh that's I totally see
where it's gonna go but for the for a
person who's seen it for the first time
or just an average audience member
someone who doesn't like critique film
or whatever I could see why it could be
very confusing you know I think they
very very well show character in a way
that I don't think any other series does
you know you see all these just random
characters just put in this place they
actually make you care for each and
every single one of them to the point
where you want to see where each
person's art takes them and I think that
what makes it so genius is the fact that
they're able to take these characters
their flaws their strengths and kind of
weave them together in and out to create
tension and I know I noticed that as you
continue to watch this show you know it
gets better and better you know tension
Rises characters change and they do that
to the point where you know by the
seventh seventh season there's like a I
guess like drastically different you
know watching back like you said so much
for shadowing I'm just like wow you know
there's so much work put into it I
appreciate all of that you know that
they're going south and you know that
it's gonna have to do with the Kingdom
and the throne but you have no idea
what's coming
no I right no but they they plant a lot
of really nice Easter eggs I think yeah
dragon eggs dragon eggs there we go
you know one of my screenwriting
teachers he always told me that one of
the ways to create compassion and
sympathy for characters is a emotional
honesty you know so even though this is
an entirely different time period with
entirely different morals and traditions
they they have a really good way of
making us feel for character whether it
be somebody who's down on their luck
somebody who is in an oppressor stirred
tattoo you know somebody's trying to
find strength you know I know if I'm
saying her name right Daenerys venerian
yeah yeah I mean just her character you
can just see they make it very evident
be like the intricacies of each
character you know and for that you feel
for them because not not because you're
in your in their situation but you
understand where they're coming from so
it's not just you know people talking
the entire time technically speaking the
first scene you see three guys riding up
to this beats out going north of the
wall and you have one character who is a
chauvinistic kind of guy and then you
have this other character who is
essentially in this moment the conduit
for the audience and then this other
character who's doesn't say a lot but is
the older of the three and they do an
incredible dog job technically creating
a contrast between the older one and
then the arrogant one
now when the arrogant one dies that's
our first in five minutes our first like
relief right in five minutes they
crafted this our first sense of relief
and then you see the older of the three
died and now it's our first heartbreak
that quick that quick because they
created the contrast to that fast you
see one you hate and one you you feel
four and you know whose side used to be
on and then they wipe them both out and
you're like in two seconds yes and so I
think that's why they're rare they're
really good at creating technically
contrasting characters ones that will
fight the other
that really applies to the children to
every single one of the star children is
completely distinct from each other and
that's something that you that you mess
up when you first start writing and when
you do characters that are close to each
other they have a lot in common and all
these characters are incredibly distinct
and that inner conflict is also really
big Ned Stark that one great scene where
he's thinking about whether to take the
job of the hand of the king and catlins
they're discouraging them and my sister
Lou and as they're saying that was a
different time and I mean they're great
in a conflict and the gravitas of the
characters is also incredible Jaime
Lannister and the King and Peter
Dinklage's character Tyrion the great
gravitas really distinct and a lot of
inner conflict so the characters are
just great like that and then think of
all the things you don't see coming
there's a really brief scene of the
Hound and in there talking with Tyrion
and you have no idea the incredible arc
that that character is gonna be going on
and seven years later he's gonna be one
of the most complex and interesting
characters I think in television history
but you know that you see and you say
that leading off of that you see when
when the King arrives into town and and
the family's standing there welcoming
the king you see if you see a shot of
the Hound riding and they cut to a shot
of Arya almost an admiration looking at
him right and then we know where that
goes right and there's all this tension
built up as the cat approaches and he's
just like you got fat and also in the
feast you know such a relatable moment
there's a couple people like hanging
outside of the feast and it's like it's
like when you go home for Thanksgiving
it was like the uncle and the cousin are
outside smoking cigarettes like I needed
to get out of there for a second and
it's such a relatable it finds a way to
be relatable at the same time completely
fantasy but it's also that's incredible
character work that they do
I think that's like the really like the
true genius of Game of Thrones because
you get this time period where people
were truly misogynistic and just like
hateful and everything and you're able
to add humanity to them to the character
exactly I remember I particularly
remember hearing when certain characters
died people were kind of mad about that
people were sad about that and maybe
think like okay you're able to create
come
passion for carries that you know are by
some means flawed by some means flawed
in ways that we probably wouldn't accept
today but that's again that's the magic
of storytelling I think that they did
that almost perfectly cuts the head off
a little boy that he's never met before
and you still feel sympathy yeah right
that's tough right right
they're very high concept very much very
I mean you can see all the symbolisms
and everything that's with it within the
show from you know from the first
episode and you know since they have
seven seasons currently they expound
upon it each and every single time
there's there's so much work put into
this that we do see it's like this
moment of you folks you're like oh my
god I realized this you know so again I
love I love the fact that they do all
that my understanding a high concept is
like The Hangover something that's very
simple and instantly gets you to want to
see it so I'm a baby I've always been
confused about what icons that means I
don't think this is high concept but I
don't think it has the burden of being
high concept because it's based on very
popular books so it already has an
audience built in it could be wrong
about this but it's not easy to explain
to someone at all you have to it's one
of those things like you have to just
watch it and you have to watch it a
while because you could you could you
could see the pilot and also be like oh
this seems confusing I'm not really sure
it's gonna be some political intrigue
show is set in some fantasy world but I
don't know I think my understanding a
high concept is it's really easy to
pitch and and and convey and explain and
I don't think that that that's what this
is at all it's hard to compare this to
just about any other show that houses
when we say high concept can we talk
about what we mean when we say so that
way we can have a little more clarity I
have understood high concept to mean
something you could pitch in an elevator
and I'm short elevator ride or the other
person instantly knows what you're
talking about I say you know what I mean
yeah I thinking high concept was like
there's dragons and and death and
killing and pillaging and magic and all
this stuff and so and and it's very
expensive so to make my budget a budget
concert right so yeah I never I never
heard that term high concept as far as
like something you can pitch quick using
pitch quick I believe it was was a nine
families five for the Iron Throne
I believe that's kind of the gist
of it yeah but even so if you told me
yeah to show about nine families
fighting for an Iron Throne that would
highlight what's an Iron Throne you know
I mean fighting in the medieval time
sounds pretty dope to me yeah
how would you uh how would you are you
saying that high concept is based mostly
on how quickly you can pitch it because
good a good portion of films I'm sure I
mean pitching is subjective so I'm sure
the way I pitched on there will be
different in a way somebody else paid
you something but I don't think that
would take away its conceptual value
would it again I can coming back to the
hangover as an example because that's
how this was really explained to me when
it where it made sense if I said I'm
writing a movie about four guys
celebrating a bachelor party in Vegas
they wake up the next day and the groom
is missing and there's a tiger in the
bathroom and a newborn baby in the
closet
and I got to go find their friends you'd
be like oh okay and you would you get oh
that's what the movie is about you can
you can imagine it just like that and
that's a matter of minutes but this I
don't know I don't think it's easy to
explain to anyone even if even if you
said nine families going for an Iron
Throne to be like what right uh-huh
that's a tough one I feel as though it's
very self-explanatory and it's it's a in
the way it's portrayed you know then
again I think that is a subjective thing
you know you just told me how hangover
sounded I immediately thought it gonna
be it was like a super boring you know
stoner film look I love The Hangover I
did but when you had explained it like
that I was kind of like oh okay series
of events happening but I feel as though
we talk about high concept things I
think of the amount of creativity work
and originality put into a story you
know so while hangover is very creative
I think it also is high concept
I just don't put it - how quickly you
can pitch it because you know quite
frankly pitching is very subjective
across the entire board you know and a
pitch can I can make Star Wars sound
amazing but in the same sense I can make
it sound terrible just by the pitch so I
don't necessarily think that
my concept is based upon how quickly or
what you say when you pitch it
necessarily
I think it's an overrated concept anyway
you know high-concept is not something
that you really need to think about
right just rights just write a
page-turning story yeah yeah thanks
Emily
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna lead off this
one okay being introduced to this this
world right we we automatically get a
sense of where we're and they have to do
this really fast because the shows huge
right so they have to hook us as fast as
they can and you know you see the gate
rise and you see this guy's eyes and
then you see his face and you see three
guys on horseback lead out to this dire
winter wilderness right and they're
they're showing cuts of the the land and
and we have no idea what they're doing
right and suddenly we see a bunch of
severed body parts in a very specific
formation and they blame it on a group
of people called the wildlings so now
we're cute in okay that so there's a
group we need to look out for and
there's a bunch of dead bodies now
that's not the hook the hook was when
they went back and the bodies were gone
yeah now that's where I'm like okay and
where do we go from here and suddenly we
see where these bodies are and come from
and then death occurs and that is when I
was like okay I'm in because things are
moving things are moving now so that was
that was that's what I felt I love
writing openings it's a favorite part of
the pilot its its natural habitat it's
you know before anything happens to
anyone you just get to show your
protagonist not in this case protagonist
but to show them a just a day in the
life as if there was just a camera
sitting there and this is really great
because you just don't know what's going
on there's so much mystery but you know
it's important because they showed it in
the opening and also when they show all
these enemies that look the Starks and
the Lannisters one thing they both have
in common is they both think the White
Walkers have been gone for thousands of
years so every single time they're
referenced or every single time you go
back to the wall beyond the wall or out
the Nights Watch there's all this
potential energy building that you know
is eventually gonna eventually going to
explode it onto the scene
but no one thinks no one realizes these
guys are back after thousands of years
there's monsters up there everything
else is very relatable its people its
politics everything sounds on the wall
and there's this cold snowy world and
there's monsters are back and they're
eventually gonna come and that's high
potential energy being just built up
that you just oh my god when are they
gonna find out about these monsters
what's gonna what's gonna happen when
they do and also this beautiful
atmospheric for 60 seconds they they
utilized where they were shooting and
took full advantage of it and there's no
talking and they get all these beautiful
tracking shots of them walking through
the woods with the perfect gentle
snowfall and you just wonder if they
cinematography is out of all and what's
so funny because like yeah you know they
they introduce the wildlings like that
and then and then we are introduced to
an even greater threat in the first 10
minutes like you said and then like you
no idea where they're going and then
where we're at now
you know it's crazy yeah and then the
more that he knows everything is they're
extinct
right very very good with the aesthetic
I truly felt the contrasting tones not
not just on the opening shot like from
everywhere from being in the forest the
snowy forest with the fog and everything
you could feel that they were in a
daunting setting you know when you see
Daenerys I keep saying her name wrong I
feel like but it has a very warm very
warm and inviting tone to it you know
each each and every single section has
its own vibe to and I feel like those
pictures are worth a thousand words you
know saying again they don't need much
dialogue I already already kind of
understood the context going in from the
first shot because you can feel it you
can feel it from the gate raising up you
can feel from all the shots that they
have and they took a lot of time to be
very meticulous with how they
communicate their story you know starts
so many questions though the little girl
too is a huge part of that then she's
alive again and now you like I have so
many more questions to ask you than I
have answered it's just right like what
the hell are these things
there's no reference point now any other
movie or story there's no the White
Walkers aren't just like any other
there's no one to compare them to they
put you on the level of the characters
as opposed to putting you in this sort
of I could say high perspective
omniscient perspective that makes sense
they put you on the same level with the
carriages as in you know just as much as
they do you know and you're as terrified
as they are because it's a force that
they never seen now let's say we're more
terrified more terrified because we know
something they don't know things I
supposed to happen yeah yeah and it's
because of that that in just this first
episode they set the stage they ask us a
million questions and for each of those
questions we want to know the answer and
they provide stakes that if those
questions aren't answered bad things
happen you know they did that very well
I think there's a there's a great
complacency they put into the characters
as well with the white walkers you know
it's like the white walkers have been
dead for thousands of years like what do
you what are you freaking out about like
why why do you care and we just saw them
two minutes ago and they're just like
don't sweat it guys and we we are for
them right that's the thing about that
title winter is coming it's it's it's
looming that they've set up that's
approaching slowly and as time
progresses along with the other
conflicts they set that up to where now
we know that that's coming so everything
that's happening also has this other
looming very dangerous threat that's
surrounding them essentially I guess us
it's always really meant to be the white
walkers are coming yeah that's right
that's what that means it's clever
because we know what what they're
talking about like when he says that is
when it wouldn't I'd Stark says winter
is coming
he might be worried about snow but we
know what's really coming because we
just saw those monsters possible yeah
that's the funny thing about that is
that even just that opening with just
those few scenes right there
they said of the entire series conflict
that we feel coming through every single
episode you know so that I think that
was not all that well done but they like
it was very strong a very strong enemy
that didn't feel like it was just one
force
isolated if they like something that was
looming throughout the entire series I
think yeah for you I think it's what
tension about that is too is is we get
introduced them so quickly and then
throughout the rest of the series we get
very focused on on Sarah seeing what
she's her goals are and then we get
focused on on the wars and the battles
and they the white walkers are always
just sitting in the back of our heads
but we cannot forget about the Vipers
kiss you know the Serpent's kiss or
whatever we can so these they cloud the
writers cloud our judgment with with all
these on the nose issues political
issues that these characters are going
through and then we have constantly Jon
Snow coming back and saying we would
don't forget there's a bigger threat not
only saying that but they even if you
guys want me to putting this in I
believe it was season five or six
there's a particular moment where Jon
Snow was escaping from the White Walkers
and he had rose a hope like an entire
army up to fight them right and it was
the way it was like that shot alone dead
silent they were out in the snow and
just seeing the walkers come up and Jon
Snow just barely escaping through a
little canoe it was just like whoa so
this threads getting closer and closer
not only that but they look to be more
powerful than ever
another thing by putting it in the cold
open but putting in the beginning like
that right before that incredible
opening title sequence the White Walkers
for four episodes right now yeah why the
moment you go back to that audience will
know alright this is important yeah
because you put him in the very
beginning you have to put him in the
beginning right
and then they would end the seasons with
the white Walker threat approaching for
the first couple and then as the dragons
spoiler alert hatch and they start and
doing the seasons showing the dragons
but it's great putting it up in the
opening scene like it's just a little
seat it's just a don't let's just dunno
let's wet your whistle with this and
then is creating story arcs you know
like they made they made multiple story
arcs natives made the White Walkers one
that just transcends the entire series
and becomes a growing threat throughout
the entire time so under the radar
it's like a radar but it's like a rising
tension almost
you know so that way that when it's
truly when like when things get down to
it it's it's much more impactful the
reaction is much more visceral that way
it is for me at least when I was
watching it because they really they
really made you feel as though the White
Walkers are a threat that could destroy
everything and I think that's what I'm
saying when when you introduced the
wildlings have never done something like
this we're automatically okay so the
wildlings are bad guys and then a
greater likely put it they put a threat
in our interface and then seconds later
a greater threat on top of that you know
I mean yeah
mmm I'm not gonna lie to you guys it
took me I mean I loved the very first
episode but it took me a while because
at least to me I like when action ramps
up from the very beginning you know get
get me started let's see what's going
down you know so it took me a couple
episodes to get in but when you were in
there you were in there yeah it took me
some time it's just like a bag of tea
you just gotta let it steep and I was
not I was not into this flavor for a
while and I just had I don't know why I
don't know why because the dialogues
fine the the cinematography is great I
don't need a ton of action but for some
reason it just it just took me time to
get there and by episode 4 or 5 of
season 1 was and I was like I think I
was really invested in in the characters
journeys I think at that point I think I
was because of you I got to know them I
got to know the characters and it it's a
big story with big big history and big
mythology and they have to take the time
to explain it to a lay audience and
maybe that's why but once I finally
understood the characters what they were
going for I was like okay I'm on board
with you you know in a two-hour film for
example you have to do that in first 10
pages you know you got to get the
audience on board at this protagonist
and you have a little more time with a
series to do that and I think maybe
that's just why for me yeah I don't
remember exactly how many episodes
before I really was like okay this is
this is gonna be something really
special but I think by the time I got
down at King's Landing and sort of
illuminated the rest of the board and
you got to see beerus a little finger
and yeah this whole nother location and
everything started to sort of south and
you realize that jamie jamie and we're
gonna become really you know significant
rivals and they eventually have a little
confrontation and then you know it kind
of hits the fan after a couple of
episodes like whoa
yeah something really pretty bad is
going these are pretty quick I'm not
gonna lie to you
when I first saw this like when I first
saw this my expectation was a little
different than it actually was I
expected something like a lottery I was
a big anime watcher so I expected people
would get like oh no slashed and have or
something like that they do they do and
here's the thing when that happened I
was just crazy for it but I spent it
like some crazy like supernatural stuff
to happen and it didn't but with what
they have I think that they really
really like push the bar up in terms of
like TV show cinematography set design
all those elements I think were done in
a way that was just cinematic each and
every single episode you know there was
a big later on in the first season
there's a fight for Tyrians life yeah in
the Eyrie right right and that's one of
the scenes in the show that's like a
moment when I realized that like i was
really in for a treat
i it's this it's i think maybe maybe
episode 3 or something but jamie is
talking to his dad for the first time
and you see his dad butchering a stag
and and the whole time he's talking
about taking over the kingdom
and he's filleting this stag and i was
like well if that's not foreshadow i
don't know what is and I was like ok I
think I think I'm good I think I'm good
yeah and he says good Charles dance I
mean I talk about talking about that
gravitas yeah he says we could build a
dynasty that could last it that he says
dynasty dynasty
yeah that could last a thousand years or
we could crumble it up nothing and by
then you hate the Lannisters and like I
want to watch to watch them become
nothing I want to watch them all get
killed
yeah he just despised the liners at that
point but that's another good point
right another incredible day but you
believed them at that when he's
butchering this stag and he says that
you're like oh they're really gonna do
this there yeah they really can do this
and Jamie's like I could care less of
people think of me and Charles dances
like that and Tywin's like no that's
what you want people to think
the writing is still in crime yeah yeah
they have a lot of attention this style
and character again I feel like this
store the duh this entire series is
focused on the character so everything
that everything that people do says
something about them and I think
everything almost forced out something
else so if you pay attention you can
learn a lot about a character just from
what they say do you guys think that
some of the characters are a bit on the
nose like we know that I mean
Littlefinger's name his little finger
and he's slimy and and do you think like
eel the whole time you like are there
any redeeming qualities about
Littlefinger or even Cersei like you
know that she loves her kids in her
family but we also know that she is the
villain like are there any redeeming
qualities about some of the characters
or are they kind of on point or on nose
uh no no do you mean redeeming qualities
okay okay so she's sure she loves her
kids that's the one thing that you know
right here's about her family but since
we're on the subject speaking of loving
kids I gotta bring something up Catelyn
Stark yeah it's still shooting dirty
look seventeen years later that was the
only holding on like in the first thing
in the pilot they made sure to include a
scene like slowly today right that was
him I'd be like still exposition that I
felt what could have been done a bit
differently yeah he was a little little
I was like okay obviously she hates now
we don't know why but it's like yeah
that's the one thing that whole thing oh
and why is Jaime's such a jerk to Ned I
don't get that either like they both
soldiers like why is he Jamie's just
like hey doing Ned you see he's like the
Regina George and it's like you see a
lot of trying to get the clown he thinks
some of those in the pilot we're a bit
on nose so that an audience could grab
okay this is the guy is because it's so
big
that's the guy we need to follow that's
a bad guy
a good guy there's a lot going on he's a
jerk he's not a jerk do you think they
did that on purpose
yeah the cat lady on the pointer was a
really really blatant one and also the
audience and they focus on John and they
don't give any time to Robyn Theon you
don't find out no nothing else there's
nothing on ours Robyn Theon at all right
like who the good guys and bad guys are
though but differently
dude for me or or didn't need to be that
quick for us I think that it was good
the way they did it because I mean again
a lot of attention to character so each
and every single character you can tell
what their motivations are and what
their aspirations are just by the looks
on their face
right right okay they've done it in a
way that was less on the nose no you had
so much exposition you needed to get out
we did it as good as they could because
yeah think of the the the vissarion the
viserys and danerys conversations they
had to explain home was taken for them
they both want to go back he's been
waiting for 17 years you know the
Targaryen is the rightful heirs you know
he the king says they're not all dead
and then you cut the Daenerys so you
know so yeah I had to get so much you
know and as far as verbal exposition
with the dialogue that that I get
because there's a lot of stuff but with
with some of the shots or some of the
characters being so apparent you know
you know Jaime's a jerk yeah like you
know it yeah you have to
I think the exposit I got exposition I
think that's one of those David Fincher
teens so they do it in a way that seems
very unobtrusive I think it's totally
inclusive really I think it pulls you
out of the story yeah once you once you
notice it you notice it go see Aquaman
okay and because there's no setup to it
they have to be like back in the day and
these are the seven things and this is
the rule this is the plan and this is
this is what we have to do and it's a
conversation that two people that that
need to that know each other would never
have like you would already know this
you would have ever had this
conversation long ago it's but you know
the plague designer called it the Pope
in the pool thing it's you have to dump
exposition and
every way and I think that given how
much they had to did that we do a bunch
of reshoots yeah I understand that agree
in the sense that I feel like the way
they did the exposition made sense for
each of the instances so it wasn't just
like you know just some ran in time with
someone was just explaining all these
things again the conversations I think
we're weaved in a way that made
exposition both necessary yeah and
understandable they really did a good
job in the showing Sansa at the
beginning she's really really good at
needlepoint so you guys she's a lady and
she's happy with it and then if you Pam
to aria hers is hardly complete he's
like giving Sansa a dirty look and then
she sneaks outside to shoot arrows and
then you get that she's a tomboy with
other things so you don't need to show
Aria going I don't care about being a
lady and all that stuff because you
showed it with the action contrasted
right that's what I'm saying obviously
expedition with action is always the
best but that I mean it was very on the
point this Sansa is the lady and Aria is
the tomboy and the rough and tough kid
and did we need to see it so apparent or
could we have learned that over time
some of it you do learn over time right
but like Ned is it is about to kill five
puppies in the middle like it's nothing
yeah he's a kind and compassionate
father who's just has no compunction
whatsoever about slaughtering a bunch of
young wolves in the just just to spare
them pain later so you that's an action
that shows who he is right I see yeah
yes they definitely did just from that
they definitely did exposition perfectly
in this you know they did it in a way
that didn't seem odd or join by any
means just just from that just watch how
I explained and they did they did it
with gossip too when Jamie shows up Aria
says to Sansa that's the twin brother
right right she's we've shut up that's
another good way so you have sisters
bickering and in there bickering you
show exposition with Jamie and then I do
the same thing with Tyrion when he's in
bed with the prostitute
she's like I heard that the son of the
King is a little lecher with
proclivities he's like I'm also clever
and that's another way of shot but right
they had so much extra so much to get
out and they did a really good job
hiding it right and that's I guess why
over over seven seasons I mean obviously
you get to know these characters and in
a pilot you don't know if it's gonna get
picked up so you have to do it in a the
best way possible and a pilot so that it
does get picked that but when Roberts in
the Crypt looking at Liana he's he looks
at her with all this pain as eyes he
says I kill him every night in my dream
yeah so you don't have to have somebody
saying Robert killed Rhaegar in the
field because of this all you know is
that little piece of information I
killed it I kill him every night in my
dreams you know something something
somebody that hurt her he murdered and
that's another good way of getting
exposition out while also doing
something else which is you know
mourning over somebody that I love right
that's a brilliant way of hiding
experiment yeah yeah they do
exposition perfectly in this I
definitely think so
the numerous brand the king the the
characters I love I love right away as
brand and the reason being is out of all
the star kids he's the I think I believe
the first one we see shooting the arrow
and we know that he is the three-eyed
Raven and we know that he sees all right
and in the first episode we're seeing
through his eyes you know bring bran
with us to the beheading don't look away
you know he's the conduit for us in this
first in this first episode and we are
watching this beheading through a 10
years old tube tendril brands eyes not
only that but at the end of the episode
we see this act of incest this
incestuous act through brands eyes right
so everyone like when I first saw so I
was like oh Jon Snow's the protagonist I
thought bran was the protagonist but I
realized just setup his character he's
the one who sees everything
he literally that's his character so I
love brand right away
I love Daenerys because the they show
even in the few scenes that she had they
showed her strength through adversity
you know even though even though in the
scene they kind of show her as being
very subdued and just a pressed
individual and again maybe I'm a little
biased because I've seen her grow
throughout the seasons but I think that
they showed that she's a person who
knows how to show strength through
suffering you know and I always treasure
that in characters characters who are
strong-willed and become better even
though SIDS pretty pretty pretty
terrible for them you know I think Ned
probably and the king the king was a lot
of fun now that you look back at the
pilot John Snow had the classic
all the symbols of the classic
protagonist underdog but you thought
instinctively that it was Ned that was
going to be the main character for all
eight seasons and he's got the the tough
inner complet on conflict man of
principle definitely an accomplished
soldier at the same time and a great
fighter but the king is just fun the
horse wants to go to the crypt and his
wife is like well they can wait and he
just completely ignores her and you know
I'm gonna drink my way to an early
grave just admits it but you know that
he won the throne by force so he he's
you know he's a badass at the same time
at the great casting oh yeah and the
ball the performance is our grand yeah
the actors that they got in this Lena
Headey is what is incredible is Cersei
and you just hate her and you know
Nicolas coster-waldau is Jaime and you
know Peter Dinklage is great Oh as for
the act the way the acting it was done
the performances I keep talking about
Daenerys just cuz she's my favorite
character than this but I'm just saying
in the little scenes that she had there
were moments where they would just show
her face and he could just see you know
her her own inner conflict you could
just see the subtext that she's giving
you just through her eyes and I think
that in terms of performance that's
probably the best I've seen in a while
and she doesn't think she does that in
each episode that she's in so that just
shows the amount like the the amount of
skill that was put into this you know
she lowers herself into the really hot
bath they have the steam coming why is
she doing that oh she can yeah it's a
figure of speech you don't want to like
the dragon you don't want to make me mad
maybe I should start using that line but
I didn't know they meant it literally
well it's great in that this season too
just a little touch on that you know she
could get in the scalding hot water and
not be affected by it and you think it's
because she's so scared that she just
wants to numb herself to the pain that
she's about yeah yeah it's not what it
is she's not feeling the heat right
she's she's the blood of the dragon
right and and then you see see the
brother get the the molten gold crown
and it burns his flesh he can't take the
heat and that was one of the best best
scenes ever and then afterwards it
closes on her and she says he was no
dragon dragon but yeah that was another
good exposition dumb but we were talking
about before when you see Khal Drogo and
he just whispers to her you know no
one's ever cut his hair off because he's
never been defeated
I just want to throw that in there as
the way they you don't see anything from
drill go but you just know because you
know that he is his most badass guy he
doesn't say a word except the word no
like but you know do a great job of
setting up characters and you know that
there's so much more beneath the surface
there was a particular attention that I
noticed for Jason Momoa character that
really showed him even though he was in
this very very very few times but it was
just when he was there he felt his
president I think that was done
excellently through score he had tension
or he created attention he created it to
ok atmosphere I guess you could say fear
yeah yeah I think I was like this the
way the score was done the way the
settings are made and the way that they
framed him I think that all served that
purpose and it was done to perfection to
be honest who I truly felt like he was a
villainous spirit in that in essence no
think about this though what so many of
the great characters aren't even in the
story yet yeah yeah Oberon
yeah you know yeah and the hound is as
mine is pretty much my favorite
character I mean he looks like he's so
unimportant that he's in the background
right now so many of the best characters
you haven't even met yet maybe they know
they did that with Daenerys again they
there's a scene where her brother and
some other guy was talking to she was
sitting in the background just
completely out of focus you know if you
notice that they do that quite a bit
what did that mean to you well to me it
showed her how subdue she was her deed
the lack of power that she had and then
as time progresses and she becomes more
strong she becomes more in focus not
only that she becomes more powerful and
you know that that does a little thing I
noticed and I was just like wow that
that really shows growth through both
character and story you had a hound -
they they show him when the Fink the
King first pulls up there just one quick
close-up of him put the Hound mass
pulling up his mat just showing you his
face and then a very very quick
conversation with him later with Tyrion
which I didn't even remember happening
right now but the Hound has more lines
than Robin Theon and yeah in the pilot
yeah so they were they were setting him
up to become something important there
yeah and now you see like oh they did
set that up to become important because
if the dragon eggs aren't gonna hatch
why would you even have them as part of
the story to get the Daenerys right they
were just gonna hang up on the wall
forever now I realize it should have
been obvious that they were just a
wedding gift I kind of felt that that
was gonna happen just cuz I was like
okay medieval times they have eggs oh
yeah those are definitely gonna hatch
something's gonna happen
they can't just let those just be there
as if something has to pop oh yeah oh
some I'll say that for later
oh okay I don't hate her right away
Jamie I think he's annoying
I hate bullying well you push the little
kid out of the window it's not enough
for you don't know that ain't no no
that's true that's true
I became king yeah look at this guy yeah
that's true I see the disgusting yeah
would be more fun to drink with a good
way Jamie and [ __ ] my way to an early
death come on come on man what's so
great about this you see this King right
up and seriously you don't know it
seriously right away the first image you
see if her you know you see her brute of
a husband brush her off and and well you
know I'm gonna go mourn my long-lost
love it's like he's a dick she is sunset
have you bled yet the third girl she's
medical question not to mention politics
differently than idea but they both got
be stabbed that's what I Cersei and
Jaime the ones that I don't like even
before the last scene Wow
yeah no kidding I can't I can't I came
in Sansa not a fan of Sansa
I love songs everyone gives her such a
hard time I'm talking about the pilot
okay the pot yeah but she's a perfect 14
year old girl I mean not that I know
I've never been a 14 year old girl but
I've had sisters and I'm suppose she's
been primed to be the queen her whole
life she's being married off two of the
prince she's coming into her own as this
young child back then they got married a
lot younger and she's all she can think
about is as boy bands and and cute boys
and that's the king is astray little
brat
what opportunity is every team Arya's
not a whiny little brat
rreow is an exemption he's a different
story
she's nice her motivation is much much
different he's a much I guess you could
say darker character innocence where
she's not so prim and proper like her
sister is yeah I like that about in like
I think episode 2 and she's learning how
to sword fight or dance and he's like
what Ned's like we're gonna we're gonna
get you in some lesson and she's like no
that's not me wait be so self-aware it's
old the truth you know you see the
maturity in the carrier and that's why I
like her mm-hmm yeah what character do I
hate but yeah I just like the King I
think how's it crazy the king is awesome
yeah but you could still call him I
always talk about just from the first
episodes the kiss
never mind about say Joffrey a lie to
you I actually this is one of those
weird things with me I actually like it
Joffrey now it's kind of sad when he
died cuz I was like you know dudes is
savage I want to see somebody go
head-to-head with this guy when he's in
a dough straight-up he would be so he
blowing every weekly depression what the
feather he's done yeah I wanted to see
who might grow up and be like much
stronger they would actually be nice
hours coward really oh it's like that
type of power they'll be like a beast no
I'm not when the dog attacks seven he's
like bends down and starts crying and
that's why they do like what 14 15
minutes do do like a good 28 bro you be
a savage
no no he was bred recessive genes he's
gonna be he's gonna be just as much of a
worse as ordinary he's a bit of a savage
time I do
unlimited power bro come on shopping
seems likeable at the beginning right I
got that look in his eye
yeah you look yeah yeah I wanted I
wanted him to survive I wanted him to
live and be Wow savage those were things
I III don't think he has a savage bone
in his body you know I hate the the
first Ranger who told everyone to get
back on their horses the first guy that
get killed yeah the first kill that was
really the first kill yours done yeah
Matt Damon didn't he I wonder if he's
still like eight years later he's like I
was in the opening scene of Game of
Thrones do you remember like no you
weren't
damn look it up right here no I didn't
like Cersei that was well that was my
number one guy I'm gonna disagree
[Laughter]
in the first episode
brand brand brand brand brand a brand
it was Ned they call him Brandon's and
Brandon brand now Brandon his name's
Brandon so brand is acceptable
yeah yeah I think I think Brandon said
that over here he like I said earlier
he's the conduit he's the one we're
seeing the show through I think the
first pilot they set it up to be Ned I
think everything even in his favorite
not his favorite but things seem to be
done for him like you know the plot
scenes that move around him in this
first episode with the exam I met
Brandon Brandon however you say it but
yeah I think it seems as if they put a
lot of focus on him but in reality
that's it's not quite the case for the
entire series which i think is one of
the good things they do they make they
kind of lead you into thinking certain
things and they subvert those balloons
really really quickly that way you're
never like complacent yeah with any
particular moment of the story again I
think bran just the the the practice for
the episode yeah I don't know if he
remains that way I thought it was Ned
for the minute agonist absolutely the
patriarch of the family he has the
typical decisions including executing
the guy and deciding whether to take the
job I thought it was him little did we
know actually another why i rewatch it
though they really really did set Jon
Snow up to to be a the protagonist but
I'm not gonna lie to you I he looked
kind of like a [ __ ] to me like Jon Snow
in the first episode yeah yeah it's just
that it's just that look I look at my
mom he's gonna geek I thought he's gonna
get cut down the first view of his dad
he's like a dog with the tail he becomes
something much much better
I think bran because you know even
nedick's he's like please father can we
keep the dogs but I wolves and and Ned's
like you know if it he says the things
you have to wash at training and if it
dies you better sell like the whole
episode is teaching bran to grow up you
know not gonna be a boy forever and then
he's the first star child we see he's
the last character we see you know
that's true and he's definitely the most
active he's he's we see the long we see
this
we see the Kings coming into town from
his eyes the one who tells everyone hey
they're here you know so we're the one
who were following brand this whole
episode but that real big scene where
Ned is standing there when cat and
Meister lumen behind him and decided a
job Frank that was the big big fork in
the road and that I thought room I
thought that I was watching Ned there's
the protagonist there because he's gonna
be the one to decide to go down south
and be with the king but but you're
right
Brett bran was you know huge part of
this episode more so than any other
episode until forever actually forever
yeah said Ned have taken the job as hand
of the king well there wouldn't have
been a show well he's proven that he's a
man of duty yeah by executing the knight
the deserted of the Nights Watch yes
even if he didn't want it he would have
he had to do he had to take it yeah
there was no way he could not take take
the job because he's all about honor and
he did it yeah yeah um now the question
is whether he should have King's Landing
it's freezing and Winterfell out there
in a second let's go kids pack up your
crap no no no no it's Jess song from him
just ansan him leaf that's it just on
say you know ah dang it I don't know he
could have easily been like oh I'm
retired you know we won the war I'm
gonna hang with my wife until I'm at I'm
dead nearly had it you're right they set
him up as being a man of honor and that
he had to do even if he wanted didn't
want to when his wife didn't want to he
would have I don't think he didn't want
to you the king is his best friend and
he still kneels of when he when he can
when he walks in and he kneels when he
was offered the job
Ned is a penitent man and he's easy
taking that job really you're watching
the king and you're watching net it's
like wide is Ned not the king and why is
this king but why is he that Robert the
King I did always ask that question well
I mean Ned never wanted
just like John John never doesn't want
it Ned never wanted it Robert also
killed the current king yes true
and then Cersei mentions later to him in
the show you could have just find up the
steps and taken the throne yourself but
Ned's not a power-hungry guy no he's not
he's not I don't think he wanted to he
had to but you know morally I wish he
didn't
that was one of those things where I
mean a gruesome act of course but I
think that it showed his ability to show
it shows his priorities what he
prioritizes his land his people he's not
gonna let somebody even if that person
may be telling the truth he's not gonna
let some I stand in the way of that yeah
he's a definitely a man of honor which I
guess I can understand that as to why he
would cut the guy's head off but you
know it still shows that he's an
imperfect character
it also accomplishes so much story-wise
because we learned all about the Nights
Watch without even ever having been
right see them up there we know that the
rules are are being a being a deserter
is execution we know that the White
Walkers exist and now somebody south of
the walls been told about them and we
know that Ned will will kill someone and
carry out his duty even the you know
even though he's a good father and a
good person so it's a it's a scene that
accomplishes a lot for this story it's
really important I like the the boy who
gets his head chopped off he just looks
he says I'm sorry and you can tell at
that moment that I'm okay dying like I
totally felt from the actor I'm okay
dying after what I just saw yeah yeah I
don't want to live through this easy
yeah yeah yeah I did
well who the antagonist if okay so if
we're looking at for following brand for
my example if we're following Brant at
this this episode who's the one that
we're rooting against or who's going
directly against brand and maybe brand
isn't the protagonist maybe he's just
the eyes through which we see it and
there's protagonist maybe you're right
there there's the others a few I mean I
think okay the main entires that they
set up definitely has to be the White
Walkers because well yeah there is
conflict between the families and
whatnot mm-hmm the White Walkers seemed
it takes seem to reign supreme over the
entire tongue yeah I'm saying yeah I
think because of that that you're kind
of like yo this is gonna happen next
episode a couple episodes down you know
that that way you're already thinking
about them but it again with the whole
tension thing they don't bring it back
up for a couple more episodes you know
it when they do it so small and so for
that reason I could say that they're and
they're the antagonist because you know
that you know what's coming you know
what's coming in the feather they said
winter is coming in the name of the
episode and they said in the episode
just lets you know that more well you
know if we think about the antagonist
being just in direct opposition of the
protagonists wants and goals
you could really think that the Kings
the antagonist as well because Ned does
I don't really don't think Ned wants to
go down I really don't think he does I
think he wants to remain in King's
Landing with his or not King's Landing
that abhor
with his family and then the king is
asking him to do something I wouldn't
ask if I didn't have to and he's in
direct opposition with what Ned I think
really wants internally so maybe the
King's also an antagonist I think they
said Jamie up the first thing we really
know from Jamie is that he never worries
about anything there's he's like you
know talking to his sister and the
shadows in the corner and they they
obviously had a secret then you know
everything about him he looks just like
Prince Charming and Shrek who's
definitely and they share a lot of
qualities too but he he's right in Ned's
space all the time you know for no
reason yeah and I think that they set
him up and then obviously with the last
shot you know
throwing a little boy off of the Jamie
antagonist one thing that knows that
they did and this is particularly why I
go towards the White Walkers I suppose
anything else is because there's a clear
dichotomy between the White Walkers and
every other human of course all the
people have their own conflicts but you
see sprinkles of bad people and good
people in each faction essentially
whereas the White Walkers are
holistically a negative force just their
appearance has its own style to it and
so for that I can I can just tell just
from a visual standpoint that this is
clearly not somebody who's working to
the characters favor
by any means right if you think about
that the episode itself I mean obviously
over over all you can say yeah Jamie's
odd the clear antagonist or being set up
overall but if you think just the
episode you look at Arya and Sansa and
Arya is the antagonist Ahsan senses the
antagonist Arya I mean she freakin
throws food at her face right and they
are totally opposite right and they
bicker and and so even at Jon Snow and
and and Catelyn you know each other's
antagonists you know and so if we're
looking episodes there's a lot of
individual antagonists to each
protagonist but overall right now you
may be right about Jamie being set up
that way yeah and think about how that
changes that's the that's the true
genius a lot of things love about the
show but the long-term character arcs or
something so I've never felt the way
that I feel about Jamie after watching
this episode and the way you feel about
them now and then later it's like I hate
you and I love you and I hate myself
that I love you that was that blew me
away that's one of the interesting
things about it because in all honesty
there's no reason to like any of these
characters they all do despicable things
at some point but you still do you know
and I think again that's a magic of
storytelling because especially nowadays
with all is that we got you can still
feel compassionate
people that do things that are
completely horrific you know that's
that's I love the way that they're able
to do that have that effect on people
across the entire world that we all like
somebody or a couple people who are also
terrible at the same time you can see
I'm saying yeah everyone's the
protagonist in their own story and you
know one character that never does
anything despicable is Hodor
we see him we see him one time he's in
the line he's in the line when they when
the King meets Hodor yeah he doesn't do
anything but have another heart breaking
yeah the guy not a lovely guy yeah we
miss you
[Laughter]
when I think back to this first episode
the first scenes I think of obviously
are the the dismembered bodies in that
formation and then those body parts are
gone that's a that's a trigger the
decapitation first decapitation I think
is a big one
[Music]
the first rape with Denarius that's
that's a really strong moment it's tough
to get through um what's interesting
about that somatically is the sun's
going down in her world and and in her
life it's the first time it's taken from
her and the Sun is literally going down
behind her and I thought that was just a
pretty creative touch the scene of two
beyond anything with Daenerys but
particularly the one where she's like
going inside the boiling water play yeah
yeah like that one just had so much so
much to say about it about her yeah
about just her character in general just
from that little scene yeah yeah again
her performance was amazing for that but
it certainly showed what I said again I
loved her strength through adversity
type of thing the Dothraki wedding yeah
yeah yeah Ned deciding whether or not to
take the job and the end the ending and
that's that's a great ending it sets up
the two gigantic pieces of information
and given to you right at the end
there's an incestuous relationship the
this queen and a twin brother and they
pushed the youngest son of their house
guests not youngest sec oh thank you
second youngest out of the house gust
out of the out of the window potentially
killing him so that's a big one and I
remember going back and pausing on the
White Walkers because you thought that
they were people at the beginning the
real real distinction is the ice blue
eyes but if not you just felt that these
were people living in the woods and you
the eyes are the only thing with @qu
that they're like alien or something
else walkers you don't know that they're
not just people you know so but if it
wasn't for the eyes you you it wouldn't
might not even know that at all isn't a
skin like father like Megan made a point
to show that this their their skin
it gets to that point I'm yeah it's that
point showing like that in the first
episode was not bad no they don't show
them as much detail they're in a lot of
shadows and stuff you don't see them
like as clearly as you see the night
King room later seasons but yeah that's
it those are the three
I feel though the editing in this one
was so silly seamless to the point where
nothing seemed to hang on for too long
if anything because of the beauty of
this world I feel like they should have
held on a little longer just because
every scene was just set up so
beautifully all the snow scene even even
the terrifying once the forests the
misty sort of playing that they were on
in the hills you know I feel like I just
kind of want to see a little more but
the editing done in this was very very
seamless to me and I don't think that
they had any moments where they were
holding on for too long I don't know if
that's what you guys saw but I
definitely felt as though there's a flow
that carried me throughout the entire
thing nothing stands out is with them
really make having a too long of a scene
it was pretty long when the king came in
with everybody and the greeting and then
but the banquet scene with them all
having dinner in the scene outside was
but I don't know if I'd criticize it as
being too long I don't know if I would
really again Catelyn shooting daggers of
Jon Snow at the end of that scene was
just a little bit like what the hell was
going on there but I understand why they
did it they needed to establish that Jon
yeah this is not like the others right
there are other children yeah but I
can't think of one that actually went on
too long no no I don't think there's a
scene that was that dragged or or wore
me out yeah also you can say
question and I'm trying to be in the
sense that I'm first like first watching
this because I've already seen the
entire thing so talk for me to just form
those questions again but um a question
I did have was I think I have a lot of
questions what's a white Walker what's a
white Walker that's a good one
what's a white Walker are they human
beings is that kid where they come from
how come no one knows that they're back
what do you mean thousands of years ago
they're right there a dead how did that
happen what's a wildling yes the Nights
Watch yeah one thing that did made me
think though was when he pushed that kid
off the balcony my first initial thought
was you're pretty close with his family
they're gonna know you did something
like that you know I've heard that I
feel like that was something that I was
kind of like oh it was that really the
best decision for him to make right
there but yeah I mean that was one thing
told me mm that just bewildered me when
I first watched it though I think they
do a really good job with modernizing
the language because it's so yeah that's
right but we understand things and they
talked with vernacular that that blends
really well so for for us I feel like
I'm there because I oh they're saying
things on top of the visuals of this
fantastic world but as far as like I
mean there's millions of cliffhangers
millions of let's first have a separate
I don't know how they said the entire
scene Oh up in that episode that's why I
say that's one of the best pies I've
seen all of them really you know of all
the pilots that's probably the best one
to me some of the words are the same in
their world as it is in ours it's some
are slightly different like they call a
deer a stag
yeah right but but they both have they
have lemons lemon cake they're right
some of the words are the same and some
are different and I would have been a
really interesting you know a bunch of
this it may be tedious and annoying
bunch of decisions where art where art
thou Arya where's Ari why do they call a
sword a sword why is that big
same word for them as it is for us but I
think it helps us to blend under the
character story a bit better
you really have things like sigils in
hand and everything of just old names
the names are big enough yeah I don't
know there's a million questions what
what yeah they even mention the Mad King
in the first episode no no and he said
you helped me won the throne to help me
keep the damn thing but right right no
talk of how that happened yeah and I
kill him every night in my dreams like
what are you talking about like but you
knew and barely enough you know you knew
that somebody who's talking about had to
be the one that killed or hurt the
person that he's mourning in the crypt
but yeah there's just housing you they
have to have those questions though
otherwise if we had the answer so soon
and just look what's the point exactly
the reason there are so many questions
is so that we will continue right you
have to meet her out just enough
information to the audience where
they're not so confused that it's
distracting and you can't enjoy the
story yeah but those mysteries they
built in from the very beginning of the
episode the big question is what's going
on with with the monsters up north of
that what's that giant ice wall what's
going on with that and looking back now
how did that kid get through the
deserter of the Nights Watch how did to
get through the wall and all the way
down south that's right he had to have
passed through the one entrance he's
thought about going back to the Nights
Watch and decided this would be 20 miles
long was another question why didn't it
kill him he's he saw that he saw the
White Walkers they can obviously outrun
him everybody and the kid felt it was
these staring at them and I thought he
had died
dad seasons later Sam is out there and
sees the white walkers passing him the
army like in the end of season I think
two or maybe three and there's a
close-up of a white Walker space right
Sam is right there with the army of the
Dead and I was like they must have
killed Sam I always leave one behind the
talus Catelyn Stark's still mad at Jon
Snow seventeen years later
yeah that's good yeah that's good
let me feel better about what happens
okay well I think the pacing was
actually done very very well
it's see cuz it seemed a little slow at
first but I feel like each again I'm a
decent Emmitt ography done each and
every single shot is done with the
purpose I that was it I think there was
one and this is the element that I and I
I didn't know if it was just for
continuity or not like they needed this
for continuity but it's in the very
beginning when the guy walks right up to
the camera he sinks down below it and
then we cut to him crawling up the
mountain and then we cut to the other
verse and we see him climbing over the
little snow hill and then he we see what
he sees right I don't I don't know if we
needed to see him crawling up the
mountain like that's I'm being super nit
picky okay like that's gonna say every
for every frame you know I mean you know
why don't we definitely needed that
black cuz you're building up tension to
this Durant there's this imminent threat
that's got the entire thing so I think
that it's best especially with something
like totally there's zombies right
technically what they're white walkers
in the technical sense so I think that
if you're gonna establish the sort of
unique force yes it okay that's okay
it's okay to be a little impressionistic
with you cinematography there's so many
dangerous things north of the wall
wherever they are that he just had to
sneak because then anything that he
finds could kill you went sneaking
because you saw the smoke rising right
there sold like a campfire or something
because I wasn't really clear what he
saw right that made him even get off his
horse there was a shot of whatever he
was looking at but I didn't see anything
and then later when he was crawling I
saw like smoke from like a campfire or
something right no I thought it was
placed pretty well by the time you got
too much time in Winterfell it cut down
to King's Landing really quick and then
it cut over to Pentos yeah so I think
that they did a good job with you hey so
again what an undertaking of information
you have to get out there to the to the
audience I mean you know thinking back
there there is a scene that I think
maybe did a little bit long for me now
thinking back the scene with when we are
introduced to Khal Drogo the first time
and it's the ceremony done that same
he's on the horse and trust me if he
didn't want her you'd know wherever that
seems kind of long that they're just
standing there a lot of the time and
then it's really quiet and crowd rug was
looking at Denarius or whatever and
there's a slight introduction and then
he rides off on his horse that one I
thought was a bit it should they show
him like they show them outside waiting
and they're like late they're like where
are they you know what I mean instead of
just showing them and submitting
patience yeah okay so when you say that
those hold on a little longer do you
think a ghost should have been almost
cut out entirely or was it more thing
like because it's shorting it off we
need it we need that I needed somebody
to run inside and say Khal Drogo's here
with all the Dothraki and then they just
run outside and introducing arrows
instead it shows them like hanging
outside smoking a cigarette like where
are these guys the Dothraki are not
known for their punctuality think about
the Dothraki is lack of punctuality
really in the time I don't have watches
the Dothraki that's the problem it adds
to their to how their culture
essentially they're very improper
barbaric you could even say so yeah we
get that
because I'm a barback yeah yeah for sure
so yeah I don't know I think maybe that
one that that's the only if I'm being
really nitpicking you're not nearly
perfect I'm like trying to be nitpicking
you know that that I would say is
something I would maybe look at again
but they're having a conversation wait
while they were waiting that I guess was
somewhat important about the plan the
exchange right right and then oh there
you go I don't know I thought it was
pace pretty well yeah oh yeah
what did you not like about this episode
home ambiguity definitely what do you
mean um it held back on something that
kind of wants to know about like a lot I
wanted them to show more than White
Walkers to be honest and and I'm saying
that because yeah I know
looming threat coming yeah but I feel
like maybe they would have two slits and
some more stuff in there to give us a
little more context as to who they were
I thought that would have made the
entire thing a little more powerful you
know I've already mentioned it but I
didn't like the really over-the-top
glare that Catelyn gave to John I just
think that there was a way to explain
the relationship without just yeah that
cheesy little hostile take there and
they went a little over the top I guess
with Sansa like freaking out of her food
being flung at her and being a really
just impatient to want to marry the king
but that was necessary to it's a really
nitpick you know yeah probably the
greatest show in the history of
television but gee I can't think of
anything that I really didn't like yeah
there's a lot there's a lot that's good
in this show and the things that are
better just things I wish they would
have maybe done differently as opposed
to data that could have gone I think
that should have not been there you know
we didn't learn anything about Rob Rob
is the oldest son of man yeah yeah he's
standing there with his arms crossed
watching bra a brand shoot the bow and
arrow and we don't learn anything from
Rob except when he's making fun of John
for liking his hair yeah yeah anything
about Theon except he's willing to do
whatever pops
yeah takes orders from Ned and not from
anyone else I we don't hear anything
about him and we don't get to know
Joffrey and he's the Prince yeah Joffrey
doesn't have a single word a single
scene we don't want anything about his
personality either I thought those were
a couple of unusual choices that they
made but right what are you gonna do
characters yeah I I concur
you kind of touched on that what what
improvements you would make yeah I would
I would show all the kids personalities
instead of just three of them more from
robbing Theon and I would like to know
what a wildling was all right yeah time
right and I didn't understand the
difference between wildlings and White
Walkers necessarily right this guy was
also a member of the Nights Watch didn't
know what that was
God you know some context clues from
he's he's he's his uncle we get we get
that he was their uncle
[Music]
it's hard to you'd think like what I
would add to this but um I'd say
probably a big probably some more action
it's a more actually that's very vague
but I'm saying that because the this
first episode did at times feel like a
drag and that's probably one of the
reasons why I thought the pacing was
perfect pacing was perfect I'm talking
about in terms of because this has a lot
of gut-wrenching action scenes in the in
the entire series yeah I feel like this
first episode was a big departure from
that and I think that for that reason
somebody else
not because I'm here's me I love the
fact that I love the way they did
everything but somebody else could see
this and think and they're talking the
entire time is there gonna be any
anything that really happens I mean
there's obviously the big moments where
they where they chop off the head and
then the in the beginning the White
Walkers killing the guys but I I agree I
mean aside from Arya throwing food at
Santa there wasn't a lot of doing you
know so much you know anything that is
like whoa okay you knows it seemed very
again it's a pilot but I think that they
could have any spring curd a little bit
of more action opportunity could have
Khal Drogo oh yeah like if you would
have had somebody get out of line at the
wedding or accidentally get saved in
their answer something I just have him
like break someone's neck oh no
it is and he's just sitting there at the
wedding just watching everybody be
violent and he's just enjoying it and
then you see him you know sort of rape
his new bride Daenerys but yeah I wanted
to see him flex his muscles right rice
clan I can do that one quick yeah killed
somebody and just like cuz we seem to
against random guys do it he could have
been somebody accidentally like drunk
falls back and spills wine all over to
MERIS that would have been amazing
yeah I think I would love to see the
Colorado you know yeah I don't think it
works against I was saying that some any
any just random person who's coming by
to see something like this they may be
turned off by the fact that there's not
much action in it in in his first
episode well it's like the first wedding
well the actually there's been violence
at every single weather every wedding
their weddings are not happy times no
their weddings are not positive yeah I
agree with you thank you what other ways
to improve it episode I would have loved
to have seen the wall to get the scope
of it to see how massive the thing is
because when when we're in the woods
with them we see the woods and we're
getting this beautiful scenery and
whatnot but to see that see this instead
of maybe the guy face bending down on
his knees and fading to black having him
run up to the wall and see this tiny
little body and this massive massive oh
yeah think
and then just added body getting smaller
and smaller I guess that's another
purpose that the opening credits really
served right I don't have to do these
big huge overhead shots of the wall
because we're taking you through the map
yeah when you see the wall and the
opening credits and then you you do see
it when the the gate is going up at the
very beginning but I don't know if you
see like the real scope of any real
understand where we are how fitting that
is yeah yeah see this little tiny figure
running away and getting smaller and
smaller like that would amazing I think
I would like to see the scope of the
wall there well maybe I think they use
I feel like a lot of movies don't do
this correctly I feel like they use the
winter as a sort of symbolism for
darkness almost I find they do that so
well with whether they use the fog the
darkness the forest I thought that's
just something I just admire about the
show they have a big great big exterior
of the castle yeah I felt yeah I don't
think they do wanted pentose do they
show like no no not a ghost now whatever
they're shooting they're just abandoning
now Morocco I think it was camera-ready
I don't know somewhere yeah no I thought
that was interesting when they did the
exterior of the of Kingsland are not
King's Landing a Winterfell
you saw a tiny little Winterfell and
this wide wide expansive world and I
think I would like to see which I fell a
bit bigger and I know they cut into it
and they do that you see the you see
Winterfell but I'm getting very big very
nitpicky you know you know very nitpicky
oh yeah I mean I will say that they were
there were moments where I was just
watching because I remember I was
editing a film one time and I was think
about you what does it take to edit a
Game of Thrones episode and I was I was
watching in this first episode there
were moments where footsteps will be
happening where no one's walking really
and yeah so it'll be moments were like
someone will be walking they would stop
and you continue to hear the footsteps
and I was like really you know it's very
it's very hard well there's more like
the horse was running and I think the
horses the rhythm of the horse running
got out of sync with the actual auto eye
and I was like oh I see it I see it now
there's one of those weird things where
I just noticed that just cuz I was
paying close attention and I was like oh
that's one thing I noticed that some
people like a real hiccup on continuity
like that and stuff online
the patterning of foot hurts still the
illusion of filmmaking gives you real
quick
- the writers make in this episode I
like this in say that the writers made
any mistakes they're great obviously DB
wise I mean they're they're they're
they're amazing what do you think I
really like the way they write dialogue
I do I don't have any I don't have any
real specific dialogue problems I just
think that Rob is the oldest son
shouldn't should have had something to
do
mm-hmm we we don't learn anything about
him at all yeah I think going back to
what I said earlier I think just I know
I know why the characters whether it's
physical action exposition or dialogue
exposition I feel you know Jamie is just
a little on the nose you know I feel
like I'm bumping into him and
challenging him and a duel at a
tournament I mean I get it I know why we
need it but I would have liked to see
them develop the characters just just a
little less on the nose
obviously arias the tomboy you know
maybe just a little less on though not
vague at all no specific obviously but
but just a little less like princess
tomboy bad guy evil queen and they
presented a strong dichotomy there yeah
the even thing I feel like that's done
with a sole purpose of subverting those
characters I feel like that's one of the
biggest themes of Game of Thrones
subverting what you've come from you
know each of the characters you've
watched them now versus where they are
currently almost all of them have
completely subverted their their own
expectations but I mean I mean like yeah
absolutely that's true but you know they
I guess they stay on the same the same
course essentially you know - Arya goes
off and is at one point clearly mistaken
for being a boy you know it's like it's
really on the nose and they should have
a maybe a little bit more of a complex
relationship between Jaime Lannister and
Ned they did fight on the same side of a
war yeah and
yeah together yeah so I don't think it
would it it was so just like we'd love
to see you down at King's Landing at the
dick the next joust
yeah I'm saying they didn't have
something to talk about like like a war
story didn't they like so how things
been is there some mutual respect
because it's so good about complicated
relationships and also there's nothing
between Catelyn Stark and Cersei hardly
at all hardly like just one line during
dinner but that's got to be interesting
they have sort of similar lives they're
both married two parallel two two two
men that know each other for a long time
there should be some history there like
there's some gossip is you know anything
at all but they don't they hardly say
anything to each other yeah they did
hold back on showing their relationship
I really I will say that I just thought
about that they did hold back on their
relationship a little bit I kind of want
to see more of it not not even just
their relationship but the the strengths
of both women in one place because both
are very strong and both have their
petty issues now to put them sitting
next to each other in the same room I
would love to see some sparks fly with
their with their you know sometimes when
you're the same side of sandpaper
rubbing against each other and I feel
like that's them they're the same side
of sandpaper and they're just I wouldn't
see them I know Illyrio who's uh
sheltering viserys and danerys over in
Pentos yeah we don't find out anything
about him he appeared to be an important
character in retrospect and now I can
understand why they didn't show that
much about him because it's really all
about viserys and danerys right over
there but how did they get over there
why did they go there who is he who and
why is he protecting them and sheltering
they explain a lot of these things
throughout the episode yeah of course
they do but but you know picking a part
of a pilot who you know or just is like
this one episode what they could show
yeah yeah sometimes you wonder like if I
wrote this and handle it myself what
would they say when they say draw more
amount just approaches Daenerys out of
nowhere and I don't know who the
hormones are
there wasn't any opening credits we'll
have any of them already right and I
don't know what how did he come to fight
with a Dothraki why would they accept
him what's he doing over here is this
like white guy with Armand are doing
just all of a sudden at this wedding how
to get an invite to the wedding what's
he doing over here yeah and why did why
did uncle Benjy let's get allowed to
leave the wall for a bit to go to this
party go to the party director's cut
they execute Benjamin yeah that's on the
bank there's some exposition with the
Benjen Ned Stark conversation right
there was a little bit of unrealistic
dialogue there I forgot exactly what he
said to him but he's like I can't
believe my brother might be the hand of
the King soon yeah that was redundant
well I've got someone at this show that
they were brothers but we are yeah and
and I would really think that he had the
obligation that he had the opportunity
to turn this down Mecca you allowed to
do that thank you anyway for coming I
know you came a month all the way up
here and then no I was gonna take the
job right I want to thank you for
reaching out and we'll be in touch down
the line if any other opportunities go
you could turn this down if you want to
and he was like that's the king no I
don't think we're allowed to turn it
down yeah you know besides she knew he
was gonna think yeah interesting in
there so yeah you're gonna do how
interesting how Catelyn knows like this
this has to happen and she she be
whether she's okay with it or not she
allows it to happen and then we look at
Sarah see who really does her best to
turn the head of that King you know she
where Kallen is just like okay alright
and Pharisees like I will make sure that
he does what I say you know what I mean
yeah and so she's watching her husband
openly make out with other women in a
party or the can she doesn't
any sort of reaction she doesn't like
look away with disgust or return wine
and drinking and but but she you know I
guess they were one of the show that
this is just commonplace for him cause
he already says he wants to [ __ ] his
way to an early great
I think I just thought of one other
thing writing I would have done when I
heard Meister Lewin for the first time I
was like are they saying mister in a
different way what Sam Meister who is
this guy is it like a code name for
uncle cuz every now and then when you
hear a word you know like wildling or
meister and you don't know what that is
i would have said you could have had a
little conversation about you know so
how long has your my sister been here
you know like we didn't round that they
trained at the city you know the citadel
and every single town has one all the
kingdom's do so i didn't know what my
sister Luise loves when I first heard it
again we learn all these things we do
learn them all but more lines of
thinking of like again what would my
notes being if I wrote for somebody
what's the Meister Brian you have to
explain what a Meister is in your pilot
I don't have a 10-episode order so you
know you don't have that luxury
who's that thing is necessary that they
explain all these things in a pilot
episode no no but there's little things
that stick in your mind that you're
wondering about some of those things are
really healthy like White Walkers yeah I
know but I know that we're gonna revisit
that and the other things you just have
to pick up in context like yeah somebody
says what and they explain this once
he's like what's your sigil and it's
like what why the emblem the banner
mitten that's later explained that Ned
is sitting on the throne for Robert
while he's right right now hunting or
something but some of the things are not
explained right away
yeah I have no idea what the Meister is
until later on but again there's so much
information to meter out you have to
wonder how much of it is important how
much how much of it is right now yeah
yeah yeah that's that's the skill of
writing a pilot is how much can we
explain and should we explain and do we
explain right now yeah to hook a buyer
to hook an executive to hook a network
to hook an audience most importantly
and I again we're being super nitpicky
but really they they think they nailed
it with with it they did they did they
did they you know this entire thing that
was a perfect violet to be honest it was
a great pot it's a fun one
I wouldn't say perfect I would say fun
as as close as perfectly the I've ever
seen there's some shows I don't know if
I should talk about realism and I'll
just say this I really like watching
that pair of pants fall from the sky
that's all I'm gonna say no I'm lost
it's Breaking Bad no that's great pilot
that's that's the other real Titan of
our birth time rate pilot violent yeah
now I think it's better than this one I
might love it by the apples and oranges
yeah yeah yeah do I think about the
subject matter yeah really to compare
this to
it's true but little tiny details here
and there about stuff that could be
explained sure but again yeah now that I
think about my second-guess myself
because Meister is not necessary there's
only so much real estate on the page
right like it was crammed in you know a
few yeah Meister like me it's been in
your family for all those years time to
Winterfell maybe maybe that's what maybe
that's why they made brand the eyes for
the audience in this episode because as
we're seeing it through a ten-year-old
it that we're just seeing what a 10 year
olds gonna see it and what's most
important to a 10 year old you know and
maybe that's what it is I'm glad they
actually kept out a couple details in
this because I feel like that it helps I
think it helps build the world like what
everything the whole Meister thing all
that I feel like knowing that those
things exist even I I feel like even if
you know even if you don't know that
they're gonna explain some of those
minor details I fly the feather they
exist
help you understand that this is an
entire world so it immerse that better
and I feel like had they gone into
detail with some other things it would
have negatively impacted the pilot also
it's really different when you know you
have 10 episodes to shoot you can
postpone stuff yeah when you know you're
going
beyond a you know HBO with that many
viewers you know that you have time it's
different when you're just writing a
pilot as a Wright example and it all has
to be is the promise was so much more
and also work as a self-contained story
so some of these things don't apply yeah
absolutely absolutely that's a big one
as a surprise factory I mean pick one
yeah the bodies the body parts
disappearing in the puddles and prized
the the incestuous relationship is a
huge surprise that was really gross at
the beginning you know but Ned's just
hanging out with his family and
someone's like Ned you gotta go
decapitate this guy Oh
bring the 10 year old yeah I think
there's a the fact that there was those
creatures have been dead for thousands
of years and ever no one believes in
them that was a surprise I like that as
love of impact like the amount of impact
I thought about that like they didn't
believe in these things but they exist
and now you're kind of aware of the
ignorance of these characters they
believed in it was just like if I were
to say dude I just saw a train asaurus
rex outside oh okay they don't believe
that they exist anymore because of that
you kind of put into this awareness of
their ignorance as a scare because
that's a community almost yeah that's
what makes it what I think more I think
the the content itself is a surprise as
far as like watching this young lady get
raped like watching it and suck right
there watching how and I think that's
why this show so great because it pushed
so many boundaries and and though it is
HBO it's still they still allow a lot of
different things to to occur and you
know of this this young that this this
this war van character who is now being
ransacked by four prostitutes
it's like this is what this is gonna be
it's like it's like here's here's the
bar for television here's you know like
other shows and then here is Game of
Thrones and this is where this is the
bar we're starting at and it only just
gets crazier their very own filter yeah
its price they pay they pay a lot of
respect to the subject matter in the
time period you could yeah I mean just
treated with the way they show things
they're very
apologetic absolutely I think it's I
think it's because of that I can
appreciate
I can appreciate all the little actions
a little more you know the the rape
that's that was terrible that's like
very hard to watch I think they did it
yeah the fact that they did it before
I'm saying and I feel like because the
deep the brutality has led to the
characters themselves even though it's
not a character based thing really the
brutality and the I just the misogyny of
the entire series yeah I think it adds
layer to the characters as they grow the
profound cruelty and passion of the
characters you know at the beginning the
saris just says to Daenerys I need you
to be perfect today and you'll think oh
maybe they have a sweet relationship
then he walks over to her and it's just
like I would let every single one of
those forty thousand men have sex with
you and their horses to get this and
you're just like whoa unbelievable
cruelty and the passionate the passion
of the characters and talking you have
you have the body of a woman now and
then he he grazes her body and it's just
like vomit you know that's one of them
crazy things but I may be off with this
a little bit I can tell me if I am but I
feel like the reason why people resonate
with this show on such a heavy levels
because I think that in one way or
another as people we exude that that
that very savage mentality I feel like I
hope I don't I think that the
exhilaration we get from this show of
the exact same exhilaration we go when
we saw the Dark Knight and Heath
Ledger's performance hmm you know that
that did that that savagery I think that
that all is inside of us and I think
that's I think we actually like it grace
of tools to some extent yeah one
watching a horror film was pleasurable
almost in a sadistic way and I I think
that's why we love it so much to be
honest maybe I'm off there but I'm just
assessing people and why they love these
cares so much in the content be nice
people like that's the sort of like
universal thing that exists because
there's so why we like these totally
unlikable characters you know when you
mean that and Jamie they seem like
normal Knights you know that killed some
people and it but then you go and you
meet like the mountain and you've you
know stuff that he's done you know
crushing people's heads it just keeps
going further and further you're like
all right I've had to have met the
sickest character I was watching with my
roommate she just kept saying it gets
worse you know Littlefinger's bad and
then he gets worse and he gets worse and
they starts kissing Sansa and then
you're like all right you get your lips
off of her you get your lips off of her
yeah we were talking about surprises
before I mean the end of the first
season is built on you know the surprise
these characters are even like the
normal ones you're like Roose Bolton
doesn't seem like that you see him turn
and then you're like okay well the
mountain Roose there's no one where so
then you see Ramsay Bolton you just it
just shocks you someone worse than
Ramsay aside from the White Walkers
Mountain you think worse than Ramsay
well remember what the mountain did to
oberyn's sister and children right right
but we weren't there to experience that
we've done true hold that oh you mean in
terms of what you've seen like what
we've seen aside from the white walkers
who was worse than ramsey drogon awesome
thing that I noticed when he when she
opened up the cast the eggs yeah
Dragon's egg
no way no if that wasn't a guy when they
left it in there because if you were
watching that it was accidental you you
could just be like I'll leave that in
okay I didn't even notice that
what really quickly what we're the
moments that like as far as the red
wedding the purple wedding you know
these big big striking moments John
Johnson's death and then rebirth what
was up by now come on what were the big
ones like insuring that was I was
literally I wish I had a video camera I
was pacing back and forth 25 feet away
like in like three feet and I was like
no I was just like all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna stop watching this show if
this starts don't make a comeback and
that's what I'm saying or something I
was like I don't know if I can okay yeah
that was probably the best one of the
best fight scenes I've seen in a while
dude that one made me so happy when when
Ramsey kills the youngest stark but she
was like missing missing the three shots
and then hitting with the fourth I was
like God finally comes up and they
torched the field Jamie comes back to
King's Landing covered in ash I think
and he's like you don't understand she's
like we can buy more people he's like I
think the biggest one for me aside from
like obviously the red wedding which is
the at most epic moment I think is when
when the white Walker right raises the
dragon from the dead and now that was
creeping into her head that was probably
one of the biggest moments for me that
had me like oh [ __ ] they're really about
to kill everybody and then keep burning
down the wall and it's just like yeah
when it's coming oh when it's the
winters here
it's coal now blue fire I was like is
that I sir is that blue fire that's all
it's blue fire but do this yeah every
sale every season there's one there's
one there's one heart crunching episode
see more you just like it just like I
don't know how much more I can take
really I might have to just break up we
might have gotten off topic from the
question
okay the strength of the story so
obviously they are incredible at world
building I mean if we're given to george
RR martin who penned the books and and
then and they've been in half everyday
but half a David DB Weiss just like
penned the show and and to create such a
world and I know it's said all the time
but it's so true and to go to a million
different locations and to understand
them fully by the end of the season and
to understand the cultures right for
example up north
bastards are called snows down south
they're called sands right I mean the
North those details new rights like that
a perfect of building those worlds like
that just humble evil and then and then
taking the the written word that grr
Martin doing wrote and turning it into a
visual medium and then painting you know
painting this this this blind the
painting this person of many faces right
the man of many faces and and showing
him and her or whatever he is or it is
you know and like seeing that just like
they're so good at that
yeah you know you're writing really
takes to step up when you start making
characters that have some good and some
bad
yeah the first couple of scripts you're
writers are one-dimensional and then
serve the story and you're just trying
to get through it but these guys do such
a good job about unbelievably complex
character and first analysis Ned is just
a really good man that got really
unlucky but if you think about it more
he just value duty a little bit too much
to farm was blind yeah and not a Catalan
you know she wasn't completely on our
own when she incorrect when she said you
know this horrors been visited in my
family because I couldn't love a
motherless son she at first glance is
just completely wholesome and then later
on it's a little bit more ambiguous and
then I do great things with Jaime
Lannister ah found that
best thing that they do is character
arcs on a long-term I've never seen
anything like it I've never I didn't
characterize easin and then in love them
watch them getting mastered and watch
the one thing that define them get taken
away from them and having to rebuild a
new personality and completely change
under the mentors ever seen that under
the mentorship of someone you never
would expect I mean Brants heart like
you never expect her to be his mentor
Yeah right it's amazing yeah that's
never been done but most another shows
the evil guy becomes more evil yeah but
in this show it's completely dead
beforehand it changes it changes the way
you yeah yeah you think Joffrey is the
baddie and then he dies and then you see
ramsey and you're like oh there was
someone worse than him I mean crazy it's
crazy because like they make each each
person's character arc and it's wine
with one other and they grow from that
from being on different continents
yeah even small thing like this the
small here they get into and I love how
you can grow with these characters and
no one's ever had a point of stagnation
at any point I said I never saw that but
you know each character seems to grow in
their own way yeah I think that like
most people I grew up find a favorite
character because I see something about
themselves in that character and
Daenerys you know has to make some tough
decisions she has to decide whether or
not to kill some people who are
obviously opposed to her that she's
captured you know what do you do with
prisoners of war and in this situation
do you kill them or not you could you
could have a very good argument either
way about about that moral ambiguity yes
and that's just on top of the scope and
the scale and special effects I know I
know
well ambiguity in the long term
character arcs are like nothing you've
ever seen yeah well okay so this is a
hard question is what do they what
suffers what would I struggle with so I
feel like and again I it's probably
small story things to me throughout the
entire seven
possibly a season so far but I think
they should I think they may have should
have kept John for your life you know I
think John fishes they shoulda stayed
alive I think because because I only
think that because and I just trying to
be savvy to my own way I'm always saying
that because I think that his character
pointed out one of the biggest themes of
Game of Thrones and that's power and I
think that keeping him around would have
mercy
thirsty represents that I think Joffrey
was that little more what young so I
think that because if you see how
quickly he can not only did he come into
power very quickly but he was under he's
given it right so he was given power and
he had control over everything you
didn't get right I'm saying the theme of
power huh and how in the wrong hands it
can really be like terrible I think that
Joffrey's like the probably the best
example of that to be honest I mean
Dobby well I think sir she's like a
pretty bad character but I don't think
she was anywhere near the savagery of
Joffrey and had he grown up I think he
would have been much more savage than
her well they're both really cool you
know when they ran out of books and they
had to improvise
they made some questionable decisions
later on in the show
this whole manufactured drama between
Sunset Aria and I will say what yeah
time jumps about the scale of the world
right how people can get and and also
this ridiculous plan of trying to
convince Cersei to help them or or ask
her for a truce yeah and and why would
you let Jon Snow go on a suicide mission
of north of the wall when you stand up
and be like listen if I let you go north
of the wall and you get killed the whole
North will execute me yeah Publix I'm
not doing it right there was some
questionable plot decisions in the later
seasons yeah if I had to really
criticize before that it's really brutal
on the good guys for years like the good
guys lose and are tortured and are
unjustly murdered for several of the
first season's do you need real stamina
to get
true royalty like we could they didn't
have a single victory for a while the
good guys they were just getting
battered and murdered and eventually it
started to become like alright you know
enough is enough
it wasn't until season 5 where things
really started to turn hey I've been you
know since it was a lot of good people
also had a lot of misery visited upon
them you know there were bad guys that
got their comeuppance but there was a
lot of innocent people who really really
suffered but I think I think they
struggled in the season where they spent
a little too much time in Dorne and and
with the Dorne story it was really not
necessary I don't know wait yeah but but
once his brother the king yeah once that
stuff that who the daughters did that
was I say that I think my opinion was
leaguers but of course they're coming
from not having that information that
that was that was added because a few
things I've heard I don't want to say
anything because I'm not 100 cent
certain but I know I know that kind of
plot element was just the old money yeah
I think that overall after you know they
ran out of books and they started to
they had to improv I think that overall
they did a good job here they did very
well with how they kept the story going
or you seem that it kind of took a
radical change that was negative I think
it's sped up
I think it's sped up a bit I think last
couple seasons they started going really
fast cramming a lot in getting everyone
calling one continent right it happened
quick I think and that was just I I that
one I remember having to suspend my
disbelief a bit mmm you know and the
political intrigue died down and that
was a yeah yes this Tyrion was playing
the game of Thrones as a hand of king of
initial people and finding out her and
Varys and Littlefinger were playing
politics and they had their little birds
and everything and all of a sudden
there's not much for those characters to
do they got rid of Littlefinger but
there wasn't much for Varys to do and
rounder why and he was trying to put he
was he wasn't betrayal to De Niro
quickly but huh why alive and not the
other person yeah so Tyrion is a little
bit overrated as well how did you
sustain the character how does a
character that's right that's a
strategist I came to see what he did
great with the Battle of the Blackwater
so what did he do that was that great
over for Daenerys he's just he did he
kind of he kind of screwed up her to her
town for for a minute there yeah he
tried to make a deal with the slavers
inside and that didn't work but that was
Ben he learned from that yeah but I
don't know he's a master strategist but
little finger nothing my little finger
right that's true it and I thought he
can't compare a little thing I don't
know I don't think I know
he's smarter than Littlefinger because
he's still alive yeah so Littlefinger
all of a sudden became kind of stupid
you know Hausa well he didn't know
anything about the Bolton's and why
would he sell Sansa to them what did he
get in exchange for that protection from
the Bolton's he was trying to get her
support no but seriously with the Queen
would be the one to give him a lot of
Winterfell so I don't know why he would
just grab Sansa who was very valuable
and just flick her to the Bolton's to
appease them what reason did
Littlefinger have to appease Roose
Bolton and why would he get just hand
Sansa over I can't wait to read the
comments because there's no but Varys
has kind of run out of things to do hmm
I'm ready to read him cuz I want to I
want to see all the knowledge that
didn't know I missed a night on this
Stannis he was a great character and
wise Melisandre so bad at being like
well I should get everything wrong like
what can you see in the flames should
keep getting it wrong like right I
looked in the flames that I'm wrong I
follow the wrong person oh no I mean you
keep seeing the wrong person is the Lord
of Light just messing with you like
what's going on
I just on that edge a good point yeah
he's coming back we'll see what happens
yeah
after watching the first episode I think
the reason people love this show a few
things obviously when you have classic
storytelling people love great people
have great stories they love great
stories and and when it's done well like
they do it's easy to love that's that's
the real surface answer I think a few
other answers are because of because I
think people love irony and I when we
see someone for example like Jaime
Lannister who we hate and then he has
such a great transition and then he's
someone where we can like side with that
that that Justin position is like it's
attractive and I think they do a lot of
that and that that wets our whistle that
hooks us more even going so deep as
philosophical philosophically thinking
like oh people can change or whatnot
[Music]
it's it's obviously fantastic and it's a
really I wouldn't say a really nice
escape you know because it's it's a toll
on your emotions watching it but I think
I think we're in a safe space where we
can feel those emotions you know the
actors do an amazing job and we get to
live vicariously through them you know
we could experience their feeling and I
think that's what writers need to
understand when they're writing these
beautiful characters is that the
audience is going to feel crazy crazy
things in a safe space and we're gonna
be able to release if you will or yell
or hate or laugh or cry or do all these
things and I think that's what they do
so well with this is we can do all that
every moment of the show I think so too
especially I agree with everything you
said actually you know they tap into the
again the universal human emotion you
know we all can understand two stomachs
if we can fathom the emotions that these
people feel and does we get sympathize
with them regardless of all it the fact
that they've all done terrible things
you know I was watching this hits off
one time and I forgot what the guy his
name was but he has said that you could
never
there's nobody could know he said
something somewhere that he said like
there's no one you couldn't learn to
love once you learn their story and I
think that what this is since they take
their time like they're very patient in
this story they take their time to
explain to explain everything to a tee
you know so everything's understood not
only that but you can see the growth in
characters over time based on what
you've learned and it's so much so that
now people will understand the culture
of this area they understand the norms
of the area they understand the language
and things that you may have been aloof
to when you saw the first episode you
know so the fact that they take the time
and the dedication needed to show each
and every single character and they're
in their life in their growth a thing
that really makes you will have gone to
this show
obviously there's people that read the
books that we're gonna watch this either
way and obviously it's great characters
and writing as we've said and the great
character arcs world building is taken
to a different level here I mean that's
just a phrase that's just thrown around
building the world of your story but
this is an actual world's a planet with
the map and cities with histories and
people and thousands of years back and
all that it's just a different scope and
scale and it actually has just about
every single genre in it from from
horror to sci-fi to fantasy of romance
there's comedy and drama and adventure
and action is every single genre is in
this but I think number one would be
submerging expectations you know what
happened a great cliffhanger at the end
of the at the end of the first episode
and that's kind of a microcosm of what
happens at the end of the first season
to another so many stories so many
classic stories are like the you know
good guy
you know develops and meets a problem
and overcomes it and good wins at the
end game of Thrones not necessarily you
know hey that's moral ambiguity and it's
completely separating expectations and
just crushing all the old paradigms and
of what you'd let you expect a story to
be so you have no idea what's gonna
what's gonna happen you really don't
know
need that we want that yeah to expound
upon the whole subverting expectations
thing another reason that someone had
actually pointed out to me a couple
years back is that one thing that
gameofthrones does very well is that it
sets you into this place that you're not
used to it shows you the brutality of it
and it shows how especially within a
Denarius how characters can change in
stark contrast to the expectations of
their time you know so you see that
Denarius was again a subdued character
I'm guessing that's how majority of
women had to be back then but then now
you see she's like the leader of you
know an army you know and so again they
subvert that and they do it in a way
that's authentic and the gravitas of the
whole atmospheric experience when that
but now opening credits goes on are you
just you're descending upon this world
and you really feel a part of it and one
of they know that budget behind it the
locations that they use the huge shots
it feels like a real planet out there
yeah with from from start to finish you
feel like you're in a real world and
that's it really helps with the whole
experience it makes it so immersive and
add everything else with the acting
performance characters and expectations
going out the window it it makes it it's
adrenaline rush really - really why
when is it before when's the trailer
coming oh man people love it people love
it they do so many things right even the
big criticisms just like yeah yeah no
problem taking whatever it's just so
good it's hard to do on the show because
they they take time to make sure that
everything is right in this everything
from the score from the sound to a
person like it they put a lot of work
into this and I think we all appreciate
that because we can feel it in every
single frame yeah just watch the behind
the scenes stuff and you see him you
know but they did a 55-day shoot for the
big battle yes
like it makes you appreciate it even
more especially out here in LA you like
you know how much work went into this
thing and god what a masterpiece it's
gonna be hard to top this in terms of
the best show ever
I am excited for when that happens oh
yeah but you know it's it because I'm
always wanting the next best thing
obviously but it's gonna be great but
for now I'm just gonna really enjoy this
last season yeah and then doing a
prequel series that eventually it'll be
like HBO Thrones or something networks
and they're allowing these kinds of
creative very ballsy shows to be made
now because whether the show is for you
or not that does it we are now being
allowed to make these shows and that's
what's so necessary that's what's needed
so if it's not your cup of tea fine it's
not everyone's it's a very hard show to
watch but we're being allowed to make
them so that's what we want yeah when
they get a chance on a creativity you
know so you're not doing the same cookie
cutter thing now you get to be a little
more innovative yeah when a leap of
faith works out for them it just means
you know maybe it'll take more of them
yeah you know particularly the figs on a
amateurs project I've never seen a TV
show of this budget ever it's amazing oh
no no they they they put a lot of great
into this one can't wait for April 14
[Laughter]
so when I see why
think of adaptations I'm always scared
when it comes to animations because I
know that film as a visual medium is
very different from novels because
there's a lot of things you're gonna
tribute to that but usually when I see
adaptations I'm a little scared because
I'm thinking that they're going to
diminish certain things or take out
certain elements of the book but I feel
like they haven't read the books at all
I probably should but I feel like they
paid a lot of respect to them you know I
have to read the books of course get
that context and understanding but I'm
sure if I read read the books I'll get
the exact same feeling I got when I saw
the show because the amount of work that
they put into this the amount of passion
that they have in this it seems so
authentic that I couldn't imagine them
miss stepping in such a drastic way that
it pulls me out you know so I have to
read the book myself to see but I feel
as though they've they've done their due
diligence with this I've never read the
books I when I finished the series I
read I think the first four pages of the
first book my brother actually has read
the books but not seeing the show so I
would love to talk to him about the
books and see what he thinks but now
I've not read the books but I'm
interested in them yeah for sure
I have not read the books either
typically I don't read fiction when I do
Rita a novel but my friend bought me the
books for my birthday a couple years
back so I have them in my little
bookshelf with my old script library
that I've built over the years but
they're up there but they're still
wrapped in plastic I want to finish the
show and someday I'll read the books but
not at this point I have not they are
intimidating up there eleven twelve
hundred pages I don't know if I'm gonna
get to him anytime soon but I will
someday it's a quick read I hope I hope
I hope we don't offend george RR martin
gonna read his books just cuz how good
this show was I feel like the books
always alright as good if not better
which happens a lot but I definitely
read the books cuz I love reading
fiction I'll make up for it by watching
this shelf seven times every single
episode I make
I would click so George will be fine
yeah the longer the neck the next show
is coming up yeah that's gonna be great
it's like there's a level of immersion
or a different types of immersion that
comes with reading books we're seeing
this show you know cuz when I see a show
I imagine something in one way based off
of how the author writes a description
but in the film it's usually always
different but I feel like I just have a
good feeling about Game of Thrones just
because the amount of respect and work
put into this I just feel like they
could have done thing anything to do to
deviance so you go to the library today
and you pick up that first book yeah all
right
[Laughter]
I think that uh with all shows all
visual mediums you should take them in
with other people you know that's that's
the beauty of film in this lovely medium
we have because we can bring people
together
that's why I love it so much but if
you're gonna watch the show I'd say be
ready for some unfiltered work because
it's definitely vulgar at times but the
vulgarity serves a purpose yes I think
you should be willing to willing and
able to see images that may disturb you
if you're not comfortable with that
that's that's fine sorry rice cup of tea
just as a warning if you're gonna go
going to watch this just know that the
story is amazing the characters are
amazing and you're gonna love it
you know but um just a fair warning for
I guess both vulgarity I guess it's kind
of hard to say after the viewers have
watched this I would say going as blind
as possible and make those assumptions
for yourself meaning if it's too vulgar
for you you'll know and if it's not
you'll know but try try to just go in no
mark just go in expecting a bloody good
time get the kids out of the house yes
yeah it cuts to nudity usually just like
that comes out of nowhere so and what I
used to do when I watch it with people
is we'd watch it back-to-back as
different HBO's they play it at
different times so to watch it once with
no talking because you don't want to
miss anything longer than anything and
then once again you could watch it right
after and talk your way through it and
ask questions that's a good way that if
you're watching with other people that's
a good way to do it you want to watch it
twice anyway be ok pausing and yeah have
your freakout moment pause it go pace
for 30 minutes come back finish the
episode take some water take some deep
breaths
but pace yourself and if you're prone to
having nightmares or something like that
if you don't like disturbing imagery and
you know animals and people being
treated very cruelly it might not be for
you that eventually comes though but
it's it's like nothing else
it's tough to describe you just have to
experience the whole thing for yourself
at once you get a couple episodes
you get into it and you start really
caring about the world and the
characters there's nothing like it yeah
it's an amazing story and I think you're
gonna love anyone who watched I think
he's gonna love it throughout the entire
ride it's just saying that when you
remove the kids from the house it's not
even about the nudity it's about the
focus have have your brain able to focus
because there's a lot of stuff gonna
have to taking a lot you might want a
glass of wine they drink the three did
you drink it during the show I'm sure
there's a drinking game at that but it's
it's popular for a reason yeah yeah it's
tremendously good
as one of the crazy things I have a
Twitter and Instagram and often times I
like to talk to people about because I'm
a person I love not only film but just
the art of creativity just all of it so
I'm very enthusiastic about talking to
people about those kind of things so
especially with Game of Thrones I've
talked to a couple people on Twitter
about it once or twice you know it's
always fun to do that to see what other
people are thinking in an in a
constructive manner okay you always have
those trolls that are out there but I
always try to talk in a very
constructive manner and like learn some
new things about the show that I didn't
even think about you know so that's the
lovely thing about the fact that shows
even exist and one exists at this kind
of popularity that you can I can
literally go talk to anybody about it
right now know what I'm talking about
it's a with three guys that just met and
we have a commonality and and it's it's
the excitement that I like to feel when
we talk about it you know I may never
talk to you guys again I may not even
like you guys whatever but but I do I'm
saying but though the feeling I get when
talking about the show and oh yeah that
part I'll remember that
oh yes and that feeling is what I like
and that's what our does it gives us
these places to experience emotions that
are all over the place and so to have
that commonality between the two guys to
you too or is it's great and it's fun
and it's exciting and so yeah you you
should talk about it with people and
watch it with evil yeah not so much
social media with me but I text friends
and family after the show like oh my god
could you believe that
and I'm subscribed to several other
channels on YouTube that too in-depth
analysis of every single episode and I
you know there's a it's it's great
because it's just it's like eating
leftovers over and over again I watch
the episode and I watch it again and
then I know that these three youtubers
are gonna make videos and then I go to
the comment sections there and yeah you
know it's amazing it's amazing I'm
communicating commenters just know that
yeah I know that I got I interact more
on YouTube now than a Twitter or
Facebook and Instagram anymore but but
there there's a lot of great a lot of
great people making really interesting
videos and theories
and there's all these people you know
when cleganebowl was like a theory and
there was I was like is it happening or
not I'm like googling this and just
trying to find all the different people
who are so it's like this is why it's
gonna happen these are the different
clues a wormhole you go down that line
from Robert Baratheon a youtuber brought
that up in a video recently when he said
I have a son you have a daughter will
join our houses and now his son and
Ned's daughters are together I have one
spot and it could just be another little
profound thing that they drop kendry and
injury and Aria will die and get will
begin to read some song and then the
king and queen what if John and Daenerys
both die and Gendry and series are just
endless and it's just a lot of fun man
that's a whole little community of just
you know 50 million people
[Laughter]
this the modern day trip what's Trekkies
there's your star trek if you're a
tricky here Trek fan yeah yeah oh no
Star Wars you know I would say Star Wars
but that's more my generation I wasn't
very big into it start to but yes it's
you know I don't know what you call you
now fanboys or ultra fans yeah the
universe it's a it's because of the
scope you can always you can always come
up with something else to see our eyes
to think about because the world is so
big there's no releasing there's a Star
Trek show coming out now and it's been
going on for decades do you think that
the fan base first game of Thrones will
be as long or is it gonna be one of
those burnout things because social
media is so fast about popularity and
and and things that are viral that do
you think in 10 years people are gonna
still be talking about this show like
they do Star Trek so well it'll depend
on winds of winter getting done and a
dream of spring getting done and how
good the spin-off is and stuff like that
and there's gonna be another spin-off
after that so yeah I think it will I
think it will stand the test of time
especially when's the winters gonna
really rejuvenate it and everyone's
going to talk about the difference
between the books and the movies and why
didn't he do this with Stannis and
everyone's gonna use definitely a strong
fan base for that one I think that it
was done so well to the point where I
don't think is gonna get just hit to the
backburner
it's definitely stay for a while and who
knows somebody in the past could just
write something else about a past
Targaryen king that was like obscurely
mentioned in the show and open up that
world I mean there's so many different
plants the harvest in this world then
it's universe I think it allowed it
build intrigues do it through its
existence so with that you're gonna have
people who like making fan fiction who
like expounding upon and having
conversations about it so it's gonna
last for a long time I hope it does cuz
I love it